is when I was younger I was really
fascinated with telephones computers and
magic and I became a hacker not a hacker
for profit like we see today but more a
hacker for intellectual curiosity a
hacker is somebody that enjoys the
intellectual challenge likes to take
things apart lights to stretch
technology and and do things that it
wasn't originally intended to do and
they liked figuring their way around
obstacles one of the ways that I used to
figure a way around obstacles was
circumventing security it was a
challenge and it was an exploration type
hobby to me but in today's world the
world the word there's cracker there's
hacker there's white hat there's black
hat and there's no set definition of
these uh terms they wanted to be
distinguished because they thought that
people like me brought you know and made
the word hacker a derogatory derogatory
term I didn't do it
thank you